- What I want to do in this video
is compare the fraction
7/10 to the fraction 8/9.
And, like always, I encourage
you to pause the video
and see if you can figure
out where these things--
one of these is larger than the other,
or whether they are equal.
So, for me in this video, I
want to think about it visually.
And I'm going to do that
using wholes of the same size
that are circles.
So let me draw them or
let me get them, here.
So there you go, so these
are wholes of the same size.
I'm gonna compare 7/10 of
this whole of the circle
to 8/9 or this whole.
Which is a circle of the exact same size.
If you're comparing 7/10 of a small circle
to 8/9 of a bigger circle
or 7/10 of a big circle
to 8/9 of a smaller circle
or a different shape,
then you really can't make the comparison.
But we're gonna compare
7/10 of the same whole
to 8/9 of the same whole.
Now, you can see the way
that I've pre-drawn it.
The circles are the same size,
but I have divided them into a
different number of sections.
Here, since I have
10ths, I've divided into,
you see that I've divided it
into, one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight,
nine, ten sections.
Over here, since we're dealing with 9ths,
you can see I've divided
it into one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine sections.
But let's think about
what 7/10 represents.
It represents 7 of these 10 sections.
So let me color them in.
Let me get my coloring in tool.
So that represents one, two, three four,
five, six, seven out of the ten sections.
Now what about 8/9?
8/9 is going to represent 8
of these 9 equal sections.
One, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight of those sections.
So which one of these is larger?
Which one is larger?
Well you can see very clearly,
remember we're using 8/9 of the same whole
and 7/10 of that exact same whole.
You see that we have
colored in more in magenta,
or this pinkish color
than we have in blue.
So 8/9 is the larger of these two.
Or we could say that
7/10 is less than 8/9.
And once again, the way I
remember what symbol to use,
we always want it opening to the
larger of the two number or the little,
the tip is going to be pointing to the
smaller of the two number.
So, 7/10 is less than 8/9.